hey what's up guys i'm mary and i'm here
with alexa hey Mary hello and we are
about to play adventures of pip yes no
this was originally a Kickstarter and
then it became a game on PC and Mac you
get on the theme but recently it just
came out on me you it did and we are in
fact playing the wii u version right now
alright so where are you right now i am
in the forest a hip is a young man who
was born as a pixel as you will see
right now he was born as a single pixel
I just look at him he's a little little
pixel guy just a pixel ha secret and he
lives in a there's a lot of secrets in
this game i really like it and he lives
in a kingdom where people are the
wealthier you are the more pixels you
have the higher you are in society and
the princess of the realm is the only
person who can create pixels from
nothing ok and she was a kidnapped by an
evil sorceress so everyone's really
upset she called the ice queen nice
clean and pip has been granted powers by
a ghost man to become a real boy on
occasion or he can be a pixel so we're
like one night like Casper the good not
quite like Casper he can become a pixel
at this kind of that will kind of not it
will so he becomes a pixel when he
explodes okay so you just exploded
yourself i exploded and to get through
that area yes some of these there's a
lot of like oh my god don't get out of
there please there's some tight corners
okay he's not why why are you doing that
boy there's definitely an element of
platforming in addition to a puzzle
element the puzzle elements seems to be
you know sometimes that you have to
become one pixel just to be able to get
through an area and then there's the
platforming element which is you have to
be able to get through everything alive
yeah in order to succeed so yeah it's
I've heard that it's actually quite a
difficult platformer in addition to
having this nice puzzlement but people
are enjoying it a lot and there's we're
time up secrets earlier but there seems
to be a lot of different secrets
throughout the area like literally
throughout the area which makes it much
more fun I think just to make sure
you're getting all those cool extras I
like that there's so much in it there's
one I also like that like the game's not
unforgiving so like before I totally
mess
up this area and like nearly screwed it
up oh my gosh a chicken I Newcastle's
ate chicken pixels holy chicken um I
like that's not unforgiving so if you
lose your three hearts you go back to
the last checkpoint which is what we
just saw happened to me earlier and I
like that I can continuously trial and
error well what is that he just got that
little face on it that you just
collected so there was a woman here all
of the people who live in the kingdom
scattered after the princess was
kidnapped so you as pip are collecting
them and letting them know that it's
okay to go back to their village okay so
there's three in each level and you have
to find them which is the prob way see
here's a oh those are those disappearing
and then reappearing blocks or so you
just have to explode become them you
have to get rid of them you explode them
to get rid of them alright this is
interesting you're becoming a pixel now
because you feel like it'll be easier
because you can glide as a pixel okay
light as a pic there's various
advantages to becoming a pixel than
becoming a boy but you can't just go
back and forth between being a pixel and
being a boy can you know you can't you
need to jump on those specific enemies
which is what i just did in order to
become a real boy or at least half of a
real boy I hope there's a lady right
over there oh I want it you're gonna
have to figure that out yeah okay all
right oh all right pip pip can also um
like slide on walls like you can walk
life and you can jump on enemies like
I'm gonna try to use this enemy to get
me a little higher and fail oh do it
again he'll respond he should respond
yeah it looks like every enemy and and
the blocks that fall eventually respawn
yeah typically or we could leave the
very serious and come back to it that
will reset it or is yeah there we have
that bud it's very forgiving and I
screwed that up again La but that's like
kind of the nature of this game though
is to just trial and error
there you go get that lady and she
awesome up she's you gone by yeah they
just like disappear well that's how you
know that you did it and I got a bunch
of pixels of pixels you can collect to
buy things like extra heart containers
and more lives and you can actually buy
a little detector that tells you where
all the hiding villages villagers are
mm-hmm I really like it's very engaging
you can probably like sitting here super
concentrated I like that you have to
switch between forms and a lot of the
stuff is really hidden and it's
forgiving so I'm never in a situation
where I'm just ungodly angry and mad at
the game like I don't feel like my debts
are unfair I don't feel like it's to
punishing for me to want to go back and
play a level again mmm and I think
that's something that you don't find
with a lot of difficult platformers a
lot of times it is more aggressive and
if you're not good then that's a butt
but now this one it's it seems like a
little nicer and easier on you i'd love
to see after the next world you spend
some points in the shop yeah I've spent
some of those hard-earned pixel that
you're collecting what's that sign say
this sign so these are scattered around
these are like you know tips tricks okay
boy so it's saying that you jump higher
if your pickle let's do that oops I like
that there's just a little there's also
skull and crossbones coming out of
nether get it down there so that I can
be very confident there's a bad guy in
there I'll get you I'll get you all
these mushrooms the art style that
actually really cute too i think it's
probably easy 40 secret little secret
area of it so much they did a really
good job i think people can easily look
at these games say oh they're so simple
you know more art style to it but
there's actually a lot of style to the
way that two pixel art and the way that
these things are designed shading and
things like that are actually quite
difficult when you're working with
pixels so it's awesome to to see the way
this looks oh yeah i love the way this
is stylized it's super cute i'm not even
going to bother own arms
this way there's so many mushrooms ah Oh
God all's everywhere I love differences
little tiny skulls coming up out of the
pits there's to be no miscommunication
of what is down there and it is def oh
yeah and now we officially yeah thought
you had to jump over those guys heads
that was a valiant try how's it going to
try let's go the other way now see
what's up what's going on over here
maybe there's some secrets up here how
long it looks like their secrets
littered all over the place yeah what's
up here I'm up here oh this is enough
much I much nicer way please oh oh oh
okay fine mr. not very nice d man you
got a man until he almost claimed your
life she got him he almost did oh
goodness and oh no I'm have one heart i
wish i had some food let's see if only
there was a whole show around here i
know a whole command again whole cooked
chicken apparently like when you pick up
food you eat it right away like it
doesn't go into your inventory if you
have any all right yeah you can't see my
wii u screen you can marry I on it has
your inventory and you can actually
upgrade some weapons you get later on in
the game but there's nothing in my
inventory right now yeah cut a little
area tour boosts and upgrades so
obviously there's a lot more that you
can get later on in the game and I think
you know this is the kind of thing where
you're greatly rewarded for your efforts
so if you can just make it a little bit
past you get to spend your hard-earned
pixels on something that you want right
yeah to what oh well angry be man okay
and now your boy again so this is what
I'm talking about when I say it really
like the puzzles you have to basically
know that you can only complete this
puzzle as a boy because you can't hop as
I mmm
no there we go up and then this area
looks like a pixel area oh my god maybe
I'm wrong because you can one pixel can
get under there see that there we go and
then if you hop on his head then you
become a boy and then you can get it I
saved this little pixelized granny up
there half past she's alone in Ukrainian
she just looks like a blob I don't know
what she looked like was she didn't
really want my granny do you have
problems with block gloves of pixels I
think pic would have something to say
about that autumn out when automatic
people who when you just grab the wall
automatically actually like irritates me
so much but really I don't kind of like
grabbing the wall unless I tell you I
want to grab a wall yeah I will decide
whether or not I want to grab the wall
he'll auto piece yeah he automatically
grabs the wall which sometimes it's nice
when you're like oh I know I'm not going
to fall and sometimes it's please stop
sir psycho you got him so very cute Oh
mm okay Oh in the hit a point and then
you're going back to work in Harrogate
oh yeah if you explode there's a secret
in there I've love these little
balancing Russians anything really happy
so this is a super cute game I really
like the art style it's very late friend
environments like go past the forest
areas and in two different you do
there's like a mountain area and like a
lava II area it's like your
stereotypical fantasy fantasy
environment and ered fantasy and
vibrance I like them I like the I've
seen the ice environment is fun almost
into the so this one if I want this I
have to
I blowed it and then jump and then jump
on him and then so you have to be able
to switch very fast
I also really like the idea of like
you're a boy who was born only one pixel
yeah it's got a cute little story but at
the same time you don't need a good oh
it's not it's not even that great of a
story but it doesn't need to be good
because it's the platforming that you're
interested in right leg and the secrets
yeah that's when I would play this game
it's certainly not because I really
loved this story but it's a cute story
in that helps of dealing with an evil
ice queen and saving a princess and you
know getting all the grannies apparently
she received like other people besides
of granny's there's like young boys and
young women but the grannies are the
ones that tend to be all right that was
lucky all right okay okay
there you go yeah on them pixel pit I
like that you have to change forms like
that's something that you sort of it
takes a couple of levels to master but
once you get the hang of it it's just
like okay it looks like i had they
already know some of these don't fit in
with the others like the middle granny
was made out of like four pixels and
then that girl was perfectly decorated
yet all right let's go buy some stuff at
the shop alright so I have eight hundred
and five pixels what's that gonna buy
you at the shop probably a flash are you
with pixels the last time I checked
prices were pretty guy I think inflation
in the pixel kingdom is hard the pixel
kingdom lugs right here are some other
some other residents of pixel Kingdom
this salty man who's really Kelly who
really doesn't like being a pixel well
that's a stupid name for dude Kelly then
you have this woman who we saved is she
nice because we saved her see hi okay
alright thanks Shireen I needed that
encouragement and here's another not a
salty pixel man I can still shake it off
it's a very varied group of people in
the town you have your people that have
eyeballs and some people here this guy
I'm looking alright so I've 805 pixels
and I can buy off some things here fire
orbs or bit forest become temporarily
invincible or I can get the treasure
detector or a villager detector okay but
what I'm kind of interested in is this
potion because there are definitely
times what I need approach it what do
you think well you can't well yeah I
think 700 you can only get one I say
just one and all right that restores one
heart or all arts that's nice let's get
it wait yes sweet thanks dude alright
and we're ready for our adventures so
that is Adventures of PIP
it is super cute it's out now pc pc mac
and we use yeah and it just came out for
wii u i just got through you the
controls between both are relatively the
same I like being able to see my
inventory on the wii u screen so i kind
of look the wii version little better
that's good well back side benches app
you can check it out right now and
thanks for watching guys thanks guys
you